annonce forte des manuels macron c'est
la réouverture progressive à partir du
lundi 11 mai des crèches et écoles de la
maternelle au lycée une mesure qui en a
surpris plus d'un on va en parler avec
deux invités deux invités qui sont à
distance manuel afonso cancel bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes la secrétaire de dans
les yvelines de la fédération des
parents d'élèves de la pp et il ya
également avec nous fabien le duigou
bonsoir faites-le vous le co secrétaire
du snes fsu suivi d'un syndicat des
enseignants du second degré je vais vous
faire d'abord réagir fabien le duigou
les modalités de cette reprise des cours
doivent être encore imprécises et dans
les 15 prochains jours a dit ce matin le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer rhin même si cette
rentrée là dit elle ne se fera pas comme
avant ça se fera par petits groupes
il y aura également un retour à l'école
kiné qui ne sera pas obligatoire a dit
ce matin jean-michel mentir que pensez
vous de cette décision de reprise
progressive à partir du lundi 11 mai
alors là non ce qui a été fait hier soir
qu'ils ont appris à courir et moeurs qui
circulent s est pas n'allez pas
longtemps des gros clé si rapide
après mouche qui nous nous rend perplexe
et nous inquiète des conditions telles
rentrée ne serait-ce que simplement par
la nécessité de gesté barrière dans
l'établissement là comment j allais ans
le fils pour que les élèves
la question du matériel et masque c'est
beaucoup beaucoup d'interrogations où on
est à la fois très impatient d'apprendre
un peu plus c'est qu'ils sont remplies
kim a précisé et quand même à quel état
d'esprit les enseignants que j'aime
beaucoup la vie non pas après de ses
inquiétudes
manuel afonso cancel la décision du
président de la république a été motivé
il a dit emmanuel macron par la
nécessité aussi de permettre le retour à
une activité professionnelle des parents
comment elle a été accueillie cette
décision de de reprendre progressivement
l'école à partir du 11 mai ce très
mitigé a en fait suite aux annonces de
monsieur macron nous avons pris la
liberté de générer un sondage sur les
réseaux sociaux afin de prendre un peu
la température parce que justement on ne
sait pas trop comment réagir
on parle quand même de nos enfants qu'on
veut remettre à l'école dans des
situations sanitaires tels qu'on les
connaît aujourd'hui et qui nous inquiète
beaucoup
mais en même temps on est d'accord que
les foyers familiaux ont besoin de
travail et ont besoin de ramener de
l'argent
voilà la situation est assez assez
cocasse
en règle générale les parents sont
inquiets les parents ne sont pas pour un
retour au 11 mars au 11 mai excusez moi
qui paraît un peu prématuré et surtout
bon on garde aussi en tête que à l'heure
actuelle ce ne sont que des annonces
qu'il n'y a pas encore de décision et de
processus mis en place
on attend du factuel en fait on attend
de voir ce que le factuel va faire
ressortir ministre l'éducation nationale
a dit 1 ce matin dans les 15 prochains
jours en tout cas toutes les les mesures
les modalités seraient connus pour cette
reprise vous parliez d'inquiétude manuel
afonso cancel notamment on l'évoquait
la difficulté de faire respecter des
gestes barrières aux enfants on n'a pas
aussi parlé de la question de la
protection ne sais pas encore
aujourd'hui s'il y aura des masques des
gants qui seront mises en place dans ces
écoles tout à fait ça va être très
compliqué puis moi j'ai vraiment une
grosse pente et pour les enseignants et
pour les personnels encadrants en
élémentaire j'ai eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec avec mes élus locaux sur
l'organisation qui est envisagé surtout
au premier degré vous c'est très
compliqué pour des enfants de maternelle
et d'élémentaire de respecter les
mesures de distanciation social
principalement et et puis on ne voit pas
des élèves porter un masque
toute la journée ou même une partie de
la journée ça va être très compliqué
pour les enseignants de réussira à
maintenir cette discipline autour de la
du sanitaire même les collectivités sont
inquiètes parce que il va falloir des
ressources humaines il va falloir
l'organisation la logistique qui ne
fonctionne pas forcément et ne serait-ce
que la cantine comment font les mais les
prestataires ne sont aussi en
confinement ne font pas les bonnes
raisons c'est les mêmes inquiétudes
on l'a compris aussi du goût du côté des
professeurs savent bien le d'ugo mola la
première inquiétude à bord ça va être de
gérer en fait au premier jour et
notamment nous d'ailleurs c'est le chsct
ministériel à la vie qui est doté de
trois rives c'est qu'il est nécessaire
que tous les élèves tous les personnels
encadrants nationales soient dépistés en
comparant visage et une rentrée sans un
dépistage généralisé alors pour le
moment il n'y a pas grand et donc évoqué
des tests pour les personnes seulement
qui présentent des symptômes pour
l'instant ce n'est pas évoquée pour les
professeurs vous demandez que vous qu'il
ya des tests à plus grande échelle
qu'ils soient mises en place nous c'est
en tant que les jeunes sourds souvent
des porteurs asymptomatiques ne
développe pas les symptômes dont qui
peuvent très bien ramener du coup le
virus à l'établissement l'établissement
elles reprises condamné les élèves les
enseignants ou au contraire au tir
enroulé leur a les cheveux
donc pour nous là la condition préalable
à premières conditions d'accès le
dépistage est réalisé donc de tous les
passagers photo ddm lassé de la sécurité
la santé
donc c'est sur ce point précis que vous
allez être vigilants dans les 15
prochains jours
je me disais un jean michel blanquer a
parlé de définition de modalités dans
les 15 prochains jours c'est sur ce
point précis là vous être vous allez
être lancés dans une premier n'a beau
site est dans la question
la différenciation sociale au collège
l'apprend d'élèves par classe au lycée
prendre cinq élèves par classe mais ça
le cours qui sont tous remplis on ne
pourra pas en fait accueillir tous les
élèves
je suis d'ailleurs persuadé appuie
beaucoup famille ne vont pas devoir
emmener leurs enfants au collège ou
lycée dans les écoles puisqu'ils vont
donner moi il sera dit certain que les
conditions d'accueil sont centraux qui
m'a dit il ya aussi cette question là
des effectifs
actuellement on a parlé de petits
groupes enfin le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a parlé de petits groupes ce
matin sauf que c'est physiquement ça
aussi à moi pour des cibles de
n'accueillir qu'une partie des délais
des coûts et qu'on habille parfaitement
parvenu à garder les enfants à la maison
et mano la faune au concept sur quoi
elle être vigilante sur les prochaines
les prochaines semaines avant la
première chose ça va être les conditions
qu'est ce qu'on appelle une reprise
progressive quelle organisation
est ce que ça vaut vraiment le coup de
partir par petits groupes
est-ce qu'on est vrai ce qu'on est
vraiment sûr que ça va relancer une
activité économique
est ce que nos enfants vont être
accueillis dans de bonnes conditions
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure avec
du matériel en quantité suffisante et
surtout en utilisant des premiers fida
et puis voilà on va être vraiment à
petit à petit les décisions qui vont
être prises
après on est bien d'accord que nous ne
sommes que des consultants dans
l'éducation nationale on ne peut que je
te contenter d'exprimer des inquiétudes
des parents et c'est notre mission qu on
assumera jusqu'au bout mais là
l'objectif c'est vraiment que les choses
se fassent en toute intelligence en tout
entre conscience et surtout de rassurer
je pense qu'on a on est dans une
situation assez anxiogène
on n'a pas besoin de s'en rajouter là
par dessus sur lequel on parle de nos
enfants donc il enfin va falloir réussir
cette cet exercice de deux
d'organisation et de communication de
manière intelligente et efficace
bon on a compris vos réserves je voulais
terminer cette interview avec avec vous
fabien le duigou là en ce moment la zone
c est en vacances scolaires mais
en tout cas c était l'une des priorités
l'une des promesses affichées par
l'éducation nationale assure une
certaine continuité pédagogique et ce
qu'elle a pu être rassuré cette
continuité pédagogique depuis le début
de ce confinement
alors ne t'était su en faire un bilan
très mitigé voire le négatif de cette
coquette et théologique en fait on fait
les d'enseignant donc plutôt bien réussi
c'est de maintenir un lien effectivement
les maintenir dans une logique de
travail avec mes aura pas se leurrer on
ne travaille pas de la même façon
distante et et on sait très bien aussi
il ya d ailleurs plusieurs sociologues
qui sont déjà repartis dans l'éditeur
pour d'évoquer que les élèves qui font
habituellement scolaire en place le
classique le sont encore davantage en
fête donc cette continuité pédagogique
nous a été vendu par le ministre en fait
des multiples inégalités en fait on peut
le rencontrer au cours n'ont aucun
argument assez sévères même si
effectivement les élèves ont fait ce
qu'ils pouvaient les professeurs ont
estimé au cours ou rien au bout en crêpe
un enseignement classique que leur en
présentiel et la prenais plus efficace
et c'est là l'idée là et bien merci pour
vos réponses vos réactions fabien le
dégoût co secrétaire du snes fsu des
yvelines et merci également à amano et
la faune soquence l1 secrétaire est de
la pépie vie n'est d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire que la pep mise en
place depuis le début de ce confinement
une une page consacrée impôts occuper
les enfants leur donner des idées
d'activités pendant le confinement merci
à vous merci à vous